finally comic-con you gave me that
justice flea trailer that's right we
have a new trailer from San Diego
comic-con showing us the formation the
friendship the stakes the speeches of
Justice Lee this is a four minute
trailer it's actually pretty long per
what trailers ours I'm not going to
touch on everything I'm not going to be
I hate shot-for-shot hears whatever some
things just stood out to me in this
trail other than the fact that it's
[ __ ] Justice League and as we know
Zack Snyder has stepped down in the
post-production process of Justice
League for a very justifiable reason
trans Whedon has taken over so you can't
help but look at this trailer be like
okay what's different between the tone
of the previous trailer in this trailer
and right out the gate I got to say yeah
the color palette looks a little
different at least in a couple scenes
and it's easy to assess that when you
have the same shot in both trailers and
you can compare them side-by-side
that's right back to distinctly
different Instagram filters basically
they're all like Big Bad is coming we
need to come together and we finally see
Steppenwolf you don't see a good shot at
Steppenwolf but he does hit the scene Oh
like I like to dream turned a gank
though I believe it was Steppenwolf or
he's basically like there's no hope and
he says no lanterns either my ears are
playing tricks on me or the dude
straight up says no Lantern now that's a
reference to Green Lantern yeah
interesting because no light what do you
mean are you just saying yeah there's no
guardian of sex or to wait one for right
now so in the words of Eadie Rooney the
game is up your ass is mine this is why
you do videos on trailers trailers are
fun cuz you don't have all the answers
these have morsels you have crumbs he's
just kind of got a piece together a
puzzle based on it and it is a cool
speech well you know Superman was a
beacon of hope he made and see the best
parts of themselves and that is true per
Superman and for Superman in the comic
books I just don't feel like we had
enough Superman in this cinematic
universe to actually feel that Superman
is a beacon of hope he should be a
beacon of hope but I feel like we need
more of him in order for him to actually
be that before they start addressing
that Superman's a beacon of hope but I
really hated his [ __ ] guts and I
tried to kill him I love when the
flashes like I love the fact you guys
getting ready for battle it's not done
battle I kind of push people and run
away which tells me he has not been
flashed for too long definitely has not
run into reverse flash or another
speedster otherwise he will have done
battle and the trailer has some humor at
the end or Ezra Miller flash like others
in severe that's rude then he leaves
that was funny not as good as when
cyborg gets into the battling and he's
like don't worry alfrid
Alfred's like do I know you like what
Alfred's like I don't recognize this
world Batman's like we don't have to
recognize it we just have to save it I
love that in general where it's like you
don't have to understand the thing you
don't have to get it you don't even have
to see you just have to know you have to
save the people couple of things were a
bit CGI one of the coolest things is
also one of the very CGI have you seen
Aquaman's Google+ through that building
it shatters becomes that like yeah
awesome that was awesome it was a very
CGI Sly Fox TV I feel like it's been
cleaned up a bit some of the settings
CGI feel like needs to be cleaned up a
little bit but there still a few months
out before this movie comes out the
voice-over they have for this trailer
and the tone they have for this trailer
is very much like yet this is Justice
League they're coming together very in
line with the poster the tone of we
gotta save the people and save the
planet for hopes and dreams up wheezing
Christmas without us all those good
things are going to be gone we need to
be friends guys friends and then at the
end we get a little bit of an easter egg
reveal we have a new member joining the
Justice League
now that's hope you're not too late that
it is most likely Superman they don't
want to reveal like we don't want to
show you Superman
although the Justice League version of
the Superman hot toys is that San Diego
comic-con so we essentially stain him
but all right we'll save it for the
movie I feel like that's going to be a
post-credits a no it's like everything
that happens in this movie is going to
involve all the members of the Justice
League
- Superman Superman is going to be there
for part three guys in the end I was
really impressed with this trailer I
feel like it had good tone I find the
color and contrast Corrections that I've
seen in this trailer compared to the
other trailer interesting but completely
expected it looks to be a collaborative
effort between Joss Whedon and Zack
Snyder I hope they both get credit and I
hope they both give us a solid Justice
League movie right guys so the new
Justice League trailer from comic-con
have you seen it what did you think
about it whatever you thought comment
below let me know and is always a good
like what you've seen here and you want
to see more click right here to see more
[Music]